landing a high-profile movie role
doesn't always guarantee you'll actually
be featured in the picture just ask
these actors who were famously or some
might say infamously fired from their
roles mere weeks or even sometimes days
after camera started growing how could
that possibly happen well prepare to see
some of your favorite movie characters
in a whole new light Eric Stoltz from
the get-go the team behind Back to the
Future wanted Michael J Fox as Marty
McFly only they couldn't have him
because he was tied up shooting his hit
show family ties so they went with
another actor Eric Stoltz
according to Indy wire director Robert
Zemeckis and producer Steven Spielberg
realized weeks into production that
Stoltz wasn't getting many laughs and
rough cuts of the film plus he
reportedly went full method actor onset
demanding that everyone referred to him
as Marc's Ari I'm sorry co-star Tom
Wilson stated that he got a particularly
aggravating experience during a fight
scene between Marty and his character
Biff Tannen eventually they fired Stoltz
and brought in their original choice
recast installed ultimately proved to be
a wise business decision Back to the
Future was a smash hit and went on to
become a beloved classic for his part
Stoltz told movie Holt in 2007 that
getting fired was a freeing experience
in retrospect still the situation sounds
pretty heavy there's that buddy
Samantha Morgan in the oscar-winning
movie her the computer operating system
that Joaquin Phoenix's character falls
in love with was initially voiced by
actress Samantha Morton all went
smoothly until the film's team got to
the editing room director Spike Jones
explained what happened at the 2013 AFI
Fest quote Samantha was really involved
in giving Joaquin Phoenix a lot to work
from and then we got into editing and we
realized what Samantha and I had done
together wasn't working for what the
character needed so we ended up having
to recast at that point in time
Norton's eventual replacement Scarlett
Johansson who filmed her dialogue around
her Captain America the Winter Soldier
scheduled Harvey Keitel Apocalypse Now
was played by production headaches
among the worst when director Francis
Ford Coppola had to fire his leading man
Harvey Keitel shortly after the film
started shooting reports claimed that
the two disagreed with the portrayal of
Keitel's character Captain Benjamin
Willard Keitel was replaced by Martin
Sheen who suffered a heart attack during
the infamously difficult production and
Apocalypse Now went on to massive
commercial success and nearly Universal
critical acclaim Lori petti
just two days into filming demolition
man producer Joel Silver fired actress
Lori petti reportedly over creative
differences her replacement a young star
named Sandra Bullock petit later spoke
about her firing at a 2014 interview
with The Daily Beast quote it was the
most uncool day in Hollywood for me I
just treat people the way I want to be
treated so I'd rather not gossip about
his unkindness Sean young Dick Tracy
from 1990 originally had actress Sean
young on the part of love interest Tess
Trueheart
but she was replaced soon into
production why a profile of young by
Entertainment Weekly said she was fired
for not seeming maternal enough however
young claimed the firing was a blessing
telling the LA Times I could have
survived working with Warren Beatty she
later alleged in an interview with movie
line and she was fired for refusing
Beatty sexual advances for his part
Beatty has denied the accusations what
she didn't like the jacket thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which fired performers
should have made the list